last night an elderly confused man went
missing in New York luckily a band of
self-satisfied elitist found him
babbling on the street through some
pants on him gave him a stage omen cat
I'm gonna say one thing Trump
it's no longer down with trumpet tells
me talk about persuasive really I was on
the fence about trumpet then okay I
decided to really listen to one of the
great generational leaders of American
pop culture and the clenched fists at
the end that really drove it home it
looked like he was pressing a 2 pound
weight in a Jenny Craig commercial oh my
God look at it again it's so cute it's
like he found out the restaurant serves
jello or that he won a $10 scratch off
or he scored a cameo in Jersey Shore or
he had his first number two in a week
Thank You fibercon what a sad end for a
great actor he went from Raging Bull
Raging Bull to this
[Applause]
of course I am
oh yeah poor Bob you know he's like a
star whose girlfriend dumps him for a
bigger star a bigger star who's in the
white house while you're in dirty
grandpa oh man
so now the resistance is reduced to
applauding tantrums who knew De Niro's
lasting role would be irrelevant gasbag
pleasing irrelevant peers and he's doing
this as trump organizes a summit not a
war a summit and you got to wonder if it
were president hillary bob's choice
would you actually have a summit or
would you have a war but forget deeds
what matters is adulation received from
an emotional display before a packed sea
of millionaire lemmings so who cares
that Trump meets with North Korea it's
no Meet the Parents right Travis are you
talking to me you talking to me
talking to me sit down nobody's talking
to you anymore old man all right he was
in Cape before I get you let's go to I
think he was in Canada Toronto opening a
restaurant or doing something and this
is what he had to say and I just wanted
to make a note of apology for the
idiotic behavior of my president that's
a disgrace and I apologized to Justin
Trudeau too and the other people did the
g7 it's disgusting
you know I actually feel bad for him
because I think he's one of those people
that has never been emotionally
recovered from 2016 this is a guy who's
got serious Trump disorder well where he
was last night and where he was today he
certainly knows his audience yeah in
that way but what he doesn't know are
the cast and crew that work on his own
show so he was actually there as part of
the the musical that he co-directed is
the Bronx Tale right they his name is on
the marquee he gets paid from it they
played the music leading up to it he
never mentions the show and this is a
show and the times that there's so much
competition and the cast and crew of a
Bronx Tale really deserved a lot better
I think this was extremely selfish
because he didn't you need publicity
right and this was their shot to be able
to get a chance to talk to talk about
that show which I've seen and I loved it
and I think it was extremely selfish 84
he didn't forego the opportunity for
went the opportunity how you say that
forego the opportunity to talk about
these people who need others to come to
the show so we'll do it here go see a
Bronx Tale even if Robert De Niro
doesn't care yeah yeah so he cheated the
Tony honorees but also I think he might
have helped Trump get reelected Jessica
not doing the Democrats a very good
service here if you think about he's
like the Nancy Pelosi of Hollywood every
time you open up his mouth the
Republican Party goes like this keep
talking and when you add this to
Samantha BC word to Snoop Dogg to Kathy
Griffin they are not doing a very good
job helping Democrats get elected and
what this does is when something like
this happens it fires up the Republic
party it turns off independence and then
it just drags the Democrats so far to
the left that they cheer and they think
this is acceptable I would say though
you have a choice if you're a lefty
person in this country and a celebrity
you're either gonna resist Trump like
this guy or you're gonna work with Trump
and we've seen celebrities work with
Trump recently and get things done
I don't see why these people don't just
show up at the Oval Office Trump will
bring them in they'll get things done
and everybody will say it's a win-win I
mean that's the easiest thing to do with
this president they're just not taking
that Avenue you know what it is the
metaphor is he can't get it's like when
you get when you're in a relationship in
which you're dumped they're still dumped
they haven't moved on in order to do
what you're talking about you got to
move on and there's a lot of a lot of
people in Hollywood who have moved on he
hasn't moved on Kimberly I also have a
theory that didn't DeNiro in Trump of
the same age so the comparison is stark
that De Niro's career is on the
downslide the movies the choices yes to
make her purely for financial reasons
whereas Trump is the leader of the free
world I think that's eating him alive
inside why is he why is he doing dirty
grandpa with Scorsese that's gonna make
a pretty penny yeah but you know what
well he just hurt the pretty penny for
everybody else involved in that movie
because he's not winning you know hearts
and minds behaving that way it's just it
was poor theatrics at best I agree with
you Dana it was free it was just like
egotistical like why take the moment
away of triumph and evaluation for other
people have worked very hard to make it
about yourself you know it's just a very
myopic in terms of his viewpoint and
it's just like just cheap thrills that
he's kind of getting for himself it just
sort of suggests and psychologically
he's not feeling so great about where he
is or what he's doing you know in life
and then he has to go we don't need him
to apologize to the Canadian tour on
behalf Trudeau it's like so bizarre what
no one cast you in that role you know so
I don't know maybe the next role he
should play is somebody just you know
super jealous and underachieving and on
the downslide because it just doesn't
seem like he's really holding it
together well I I really liked him and
I'm gonna meet the parents and the
Fockers
watch your mouth Bibble it's over from
the
now so so want it I get the impression
that all you have to do is swear you
don't need to have any kind of
intellectual argument let's swear it
works it actually works you know I don't
I when I hear you talk about Robertson
you're in this way I think oh it must be
some like B or C list actor they're
telling about their time at Robert De
Niro who is one of the greatest American
acts of all that question yes but now I
don't think Robert De Niro's in any
trouble I think in fact Robert De Niro
standing up there he's the Raging Bull
in a rage over the outrageous behavior
of this president and it's not that he
can't get over 16 Greg it's that he
can't get over but the current
contemporary reality of things like
separating children from their parents
didn't do that oh that's not the
President Obama and I see and let me
just say I can't get over the idea and I
think this is what you're seeing
reflected that this president creates
chaos antagonize methylome allies
embraces Putin has an ongoing
investigation which he says is going to
pardon them stuff people are like what
the so when you see Robert DeNiro
who's a truly distinguished actor and a
great American dude that may be the
reason that people stand up and applaud
is because they agree with what they
have to you think this is helpful
I would say happy things they have to
their on camera imagine if you didn't
sit in imagine if you sat if you were
sitting down how much grief you would
have gotten he's like what the clap
horns I think in the conservative echo
chamber oh now there you got what about
is them the rules I was waiting for
somebody to write some new lines forever
I think you did pretty well cuz I think
they we have a low standard if that's a
good line